all right forget politics I've always
liked Drew Barrymore born into Hollywood
royalty she ooh star power from a very
young age you remember how you got the
role in E.T well they interviewed me for
Poltergeist first and she said she's not
really like the girl who's in the park
in the script so so Kathy Kennedy the
producer of BT said well maybe she's
right for E.T root beer
[Music]
I appreciate it very much
at the age of seven when most of us were
playing hide and go seek she knew the
power of film and how to use the camera
for maximum effect incredibly talented
but by the way she still does know how
to use the camera like when she
interviewed trans activists and
influencer Dylan Mulvaney yesterday
it's very personal for me in a world
where we're all trying to figure out who
we're supposed to be the risk yes
bravery oh my gosh I had no idea how
vulnerable I was even willing to get I
think coming out can be so um intense
and you know I kind of wanted to add
some some humor it's my lifeline now I I
do think that there was so much that
came up this year that I had no idea
that I was going to have to figure out
in Womanhood and and vulnerable things
that I didn't even know were there
well Mulvaney is a Tick-Tock star whose
series 365 days of girlhood became a
Smash Hit
Mulvaney of course is not a girl but a
transgender who dresses like Jackie O
answering the haters with a syrupy style
and a love yourself message which drove
Drew to her knees where do you find the
strength to keep being the joy well I
think having my chosen family and the
people that I love to take care of me I
look at someone like you and I can't
imagine anybody disliking you oh please
do you know do you want to know
ironically who uh dislikes me the most
sometimes myself oh me too oh and but
[Applause]
that wasn't planned out or anything now
let's pause for a moment what does it
mean to young women the senior just saw
play out that one of the most
well-connected and successful women in
Hollywood
gets on her knees to pay homage to a
biological man who makes money advising
women on how to be women
how to cope as women
how is this female empowerment oh and
note the devious message from Mulvaney
about her chosen family the implicit
message here your actual family probably
won't celebrate your gender transition
so the heck with them
now how insulting ultimately to women
whose real world concerns are much more
pragmatic like paying the mortgage
making sure their kids are safe that
they're learning and as far as uniquely
female challenges from menopause to
childbirth to breastfeeding Mulvaney
isn't the place to look for answers here
now Democrats like to claim that they
have a monopoly on protecting women and
girls
human rights are women's rights and
women's rights are human rights once and
for all this is part of that girl power
Network This Is How We rise up together
I take some for lack of a better term
badass Glee in just saying women you
know how to get it done because I want
women to see that you do not get pushed
around
but that is precisely what the Rabid
force is relentlessly sell the
transculture are doing
I was forced to compete against two
biological males all throughout High
School I raced against these athletes
over a dozen times and every single time
I lost this is just not okay and it's
not fair and you know we're dealing with
something that's completely out of our
control when we're racing you know
biological males the fact that that's
still happening that women are still
losing to biological males in their own
sport shows why we need more female
athletes to speak up about this
okay well if you're a female athlete and
you have the temerity like those women
did to complain about having a
biological man compete against you you
may just be canceled
this is what happened to a girls school
basketball team in Vermont last month
the Christian School forfeited a playoff
game because the opposing team had a
biological male on the roster well today
we learned that the team for just
defaulting on that one game
is now banned from playing in future
tournaments
wow
Drew Barrymore types would probably call
them all bigots
when they're really just acting in
accordance with their faith and yes
their truth
let me ask you about the negativity how
have you dealt with it and and what's an
approach you take what's your self-talk
what do you filter
is this where feminism in 2023 has
arrived
for women to be socially accepted today
they need to prostrate themselves to men
who identify as women
but this of course isn't the first time
the left has signaled subservience to
left-wing ideology
those who wish to we will now kneel for
our moment of silence
[Music]
thank you
it was bad enough when the kneeling was
to Black lives matter a corrupt
neo-marxist organization but now women
are supposed to be willing to give up
all the gains they've made in business
in sports and cheer for biological men
taking their spots
and the message isn't just that you have
to be okay with biological boys and men
taking your opportunities you must be
willing to share bathrooms and locker
rooms with them as well
Mr President this is my 221st day of
publicly transitioning I love it do you
think States should have a right to ban
gender affirming health care I don't
think any state or anybody should have
the right to do that
as a moral question as legal question
you should have every single solitary
right including including use of your
gender identity bathrooms when public
yeah that's the leader of the Free World
and it gets worse what about those who
stepped up to respond to the growing
outrage
what's going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing I mean what what what are
they thinking about here
now can you imagine how this looks on
the international scene
America is being battered by inflation
banking stresses that he caused it's
bogged down in a proxy war in Ukraine
that he started
I mean in response obviously and this is
what Biden chooses to focus on
I was a senior in high school and my dad
was dropping me off I remember about to
get out of the car and I looked to my
right and two well-dressed men in suits
kissed each other and I never forget I
turn to look to my dad he said Joey it's
simple they love each other
it's simple no I'm not joking
yeah Wilmington Delaware Circa 1961 that
story happened just like he was a civil
rights activist who was repeatedly
arrested or an award-winning student who
earned three degrees
or he's at home among Puerto Ricans and
the Puerto Rican culture all of that was
made up to
and by the way for decades after this
Epiphany Biden opposed gay marriage
remember saying it should be between a
man and a woman
now this anti-woman woke up session
hasn't just compelled Biden to make
stuff up it's compelled medical schools
to do the same Indiana University School
of Medicine is now forcing all students
to read lessons that insist that
cervical cancer screening is not just
for women but biological men as well
well it's that way in order to avoid
offending certain patients
now you notice they are never worried
about offending women who think this is
both anti-science and anti-women they're
not worried about that at all
so now 60 years after the Advent of the
modern women's rights movement the left
has effectively made women irrelevant
a spot that a young woman could get in
college admissions positions in
Corporate America and the military in
sports and government
can all now be taken by men
and women
you need to affirmatively celebrate this
complain and again be ostracized
well I have a message to all women
watching out there
you who reject the promoters of this new
Trans patriarchy never forget
you are the Courageous Courageous ones
you are uniquely created by God with
biological gifts that a man will never
and can never have hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else